the rattling noise of sewing machines
has become the soundtrack of Alice's
childhood she works 12 hours a day
Monday to Friday in this clothing
workshop in Istanbul the women here are
sewing underwear and Aras has to make
sure they never run out of fabric
she earns about 50 cents an hour of
course I'd rather go to school but it's
just not possible we have to pay a lot
of rent and food the water bill
everything is expensive that's why I
need to work and help my family
Alice is 11 years old and not the only
child in this workshop Musa has been
working here for two years like others
he is from Syria
Khalil from Damascus is 13 he is the
oldest among the kids the youngest here
is only 6 years old
the Turkish owner lets us film but only
because we promised we would not show
him in our report child labor is illegal
in Turkey
the owner knows this but says the
families would be much worse off without
the work these children might be safe
from the war and terror back home in
Syria but what they really need now is
education and a chance to build a future
despite efforts by the Turkish
government to get refugee children off
the streets and into public schools many
here remain out of the classroom many
other children are sent out by the
parents to beg on the streets they can
be seen everywhere in Istanbul up to 1
million Syrian refugees live in the city
about one-third of them are children no
one knows exactly how many of them are
working instead of going to school Alice
has finished work for today she takes me
home with her to meet her family she has
two little sisters her mother is
pregnant and had to stop working they
don't receive any financial support from
the Turkish state her father found a job
but even with the money Alice earns they
can still only barely make ends meet we
have to send her to work we don't have
any other choice every morning she cries
and tells me I want to go to school it's
heartbreaking I know she is too young to
work and many people would not offer her
a job because she's still a child but I
know the owner of that clothing workshop
and he said he wants to help us in Syria
I was the only one working and it was
enough to support my family even my
parents but here it's different
rent the kids expenses I just can't do
it all on my own I meet Akram Imam Ola
one of his stumbles district mayors he
admits that child labour is a problem in
Turkey one that has grown with the
arrival of the Syrian refugees our
options are limited do we try to get
these children into our schools give
them books and pens and school bags of
course we do get in your alarma but we
don't always reach all of them it's
often the case that more help is needed
then we are able to give that's why
others are trying to help in Alice's
neighborhood Syrian teachers are giving
classes even on weekends for children
who otherwise wouldn't be able to attend
school
Turkish Arabic or math the basics at
least for eros these are precious
moments when the sewing machines stop
rattling and she can be a child again if
only for a few hours